well let's talk about families though
because we have this this is a story
from the new york times this is huge
oklahoma lawmakers approve near total
ban on abortion the measure is part of a
wave of stringent abortion restrictions
enacted by legislators and
republican-led states
lawmakers in oklahoma on tuesday
approved a near total ban on abortion
making it the latest republican led
state to forge ahead with these
restrictions
the measure senate bill 612 would make
performing an abortion except to save
the life of a pregnant woman in a
medical emergency a felony punishable by
up to 10 years in prison or a fine of a
hundred thousand dollars now consider
that in an emergency that means the
doctor can be like we've determined that
you know if you keep carrying this baby
within the span of a month or two you
and the baby will die and that's still
not a valid reason to have an abortion
unless i guess you can argue that two
months that time duration that duration
uh is not a contributing factor to
whether it is or isn't an emergency the
felony goes to the doctor
not the mother yeah yes performing also
when you're talking about um these
instances of medical necessity
oftentimes what they're referring to is
procedures which are not actually
technically abortions but could result
in the death of the unborn child if they
perform the operation to save the mother
so i'm curious to know which exceptions
are actually being made i think check
this out this is really really
interesting
they say if the passage uh its passage
came after oklahoma became a major
destination for women from texas who are
seeking abortions right after that state
enacted a law abandoning the procedure
after about six weeks a very early stage
of pregnancy if allowed to take effect
sb 612 would be devastating for both
oklahomans and texans who continue to
seek care in oklahoma a coalition of
abortion rights groups including the
aclu of oklahoma and oklahoma call for
reproductive justice said in a statement
nearly half of the patients oklahoma
providers are currently seeing are
medical refugees from texas now
oklahomans could face a future where
they would have no place left in their
state to go to seek this basic health
care
i want to point out man
i was i was i asked this question before
i want to avoid making very hard
predictions but
i believe abortion may be a major
catalyst for
this this looming civil war whatever
conflict we're in we're at the point now
where
it seems things have calmed down there's
a meme where it's like where'd anti-fun
blm go people must have not been paying
their bills and i'm just like yo it's
winter come on come on yeah they can't
be out there now it's too cold right
summer is when things get crazy and they
and they tend to they only want to fight
fascism when the weather's good it's
weird but also take a look at what's
happening but take a look at what's
happening politically with like january
6th
filing subpoenas against people they're
having to pay hundreds of thousands of
dollars to to combat these subpoenas
they're being charged with contempt so
it's still very much hot in terms of
some kind of escalating conflict now
with oklahoma outright being we've got
too many refugees from texas who want
abortion so we're going to ban it
basically outright
this is going to be a major catalyst
because at the same time this is
happening colorado does the inverse the
right to abortion in colorado is now
guaranteed under state law with no
restrictions so my understanding is this
is up to the point of birth is that it
well i read the law and there were no
limits or restrictions
so
probably right i mean there wasn't there
were no limitations at all it was a
four-page law
and yeah it did not it didn't say that
you couldn't have an abortion at any
point blue states there's 15 states that
are similar colorado wanted colorado
said that they wanted to be a sanctuary
state for abortion and so did california
and both of those california i know
um was putting money in place in order
to help women who are poor get there
so that they could have their
pregnancies terminated in the state
the point is there's no compromise on
this issue at all yeah anymore there
used to be there used to be compromises
saying safe legal and rare that used to
be real i feel like that was even bill
clinton
that was the that was the old idea was
where we are where we are now is
oklahoma says no colorado says no
problem and there's like literally no
middle ground of like well maybe there
are some conversations we should have
about medical issues nope well several
years ago a couple years ago remember it
started i think it was lindy west
started saying shout your abortion and
there was this whole thing about like be
proud of it and i think that totally
backfired you know i personally have
never been in favor of abortion but i've
been like okay safe legal and rare i
guess that makes sense and then as soon
as it started being like pro-abortion i
was like and i'm now entirely 100
thoroughly i don't think it's a catalyst
for civil war but i do think this is a
catalyst for potential second um
presidential um term for joe biden
because i think this is an issue that so
many liberals and leftists are so
passionate about also i feel like this
is an issue that traditionally
right-wingers only played lip service to
i feel like the republican party it's
made up of three core groups the neolibs
the neocons and the traditionalists and
the only people who really care about
the issue are the traditionalists also
like
donald trump only became pro-life when
he was running for president to pay more
lip service to this group another issue
hold on i got to answer at least one of
the points i disagree um to democrats
this is a virtue signal but not a strong
moral issue
democrats are not do not bel so the
democrat view on abortion is
you're flushing away human waste they
consider it no different than taking a
dump in the toilet they say right so
it's just it's a clump of cells who
cares the conservative position is you
murdered a baby yeah there's a very
strong conservative moral position
opposed to this there is not a very
strong moral position in support of it
there's a virtue signal do you think
this is a number one issue for more
democrats or a number one issue for more
republicans that's a good question well
you think it's a number one issue for
more republicans i'd say democrats
because they women's health means
nothing more than abortion when we talk
about women's rights in this country
nowadays we're exclusively talking about
abortions i'll let you get to your point
in a second though no the same thing
with this oklahoma bill um where the the
same issue that they faced in texas was
that people are just going to different
places to get their abortions and these
are really just affecting poor people
differently but they will just go to
other places to get their abortions you
can't take like michelle wolf who goes
on stage and goes you get an abortion
and you're getting involved that's
disgusting and you can't take lena
dunham who says she wished he had one
and compare that in terms of she wished
she had one even though she can't take
that in terms of motivating factor and
compare it to conservatives saying you
are literally murdering babies and we
will stop you it's hard to get in the
middle of this rhetoric but one last
point that's also going to make this
very difficult to enforce her once it is
illegal or if roe v wade was ever
overturned it would go back to the
states but then in the states where it
is illegal the abortion pill and
different medical technology exists such
that abortions are extremely easy to
have even without having a doctor so
because during covid we weren't allowed
to meet with doctors that you had to
meet with a doctor to get yourself an
abortion pill prescribed to you but
during kovid they lifted that because
they didn't want people meeting with
doctors now since they're changing that
rule they're getting abortion pills
mailed in from different countries and
different continents and there's not a
lot you could do to stop this we're not
going to start making this illegal for
women to get the abortion pill off the
market we're not going to jail them
right that's uh the worst political move
to try to penalize the woman for getting
it
i just think it's a losing issue i want
to mention i i want to kind of interject
here because this is i think important
issue for me uh so you mentioned that
left wingers more or less see this as an
arbitrary medical procedure that people
are only opposing for these archaic
religious reasons on the right people
see this as the termination of a human
life earlier we were talking about the
fact that there used to be middle ground
on this issue i think the fact that
there isn't any more just means that
we've all become more honest with each
other and with ourselves because this
isn't an issue where there can be any
middle ground either you're slaughtering
a child or you're not i think with
respect to
looking at alternatives women may pursue
if their state illegalizes abortion we
know that even though people did flee to
other states overall abortion in texas
went down by about 60 percent so some
lives are being saved by this law again
it can be difficult to quantify but the
more states outlaw abortion the more or
the fewer unborn children we will see
dying and i don't think there's any
pro-lifer who's going to say that's not
a win just because some people aren't
following that law it's tragic when that
law isn't followed it's tragic whenever
an unborn child is killed but banning
that and seeing it occur less often is a
move in the right direction
liberals are motivated by tribal care
tribalism care and fairness they will
they will march if told to march and
they typically will get away with it if
that means slamming uh banging on the
doors of the supreme court you know our
senate building because brett kavanaugh
is there and they scream that he's a
violate or whatever if they're told to
do it they'll do it so you don't need
abortion to motivate the left to go out
and protest for something
the right is motivated by very little
this is one of the big issues that has
motivated them to actually get out and
protest in fact there's a progressive
pro-lifer right now she gave a press
conference because apparently she had
taken baby parts from a university that
they got access to and she took them and
uh i don't know i don't know exactly the
full story apparently she was giving
burials to the babies or something to
that effect i'm not entirely sure
people are trying to claim that she's
like gosnell 2 or something like that
but she's actually a progressive
pro-lifer these were given to her like
it was a whistleblower situation oh is
that what it was yeah yeah okay so so
you so when it comes to pro-life
you really just have to look at it like
take a look at how the left describes
the issue of abortion when they're like
what happens if you have a miscarriage
and it's just a clump of cells versus a
baby being killed like people will run
into a burning building to save a baby
they won't run into a burning building
to take a dump yeah there's there's
there's there's not a motor there's a
clear motivate motivational distinction
here are you guys life like
conceptioners yeah i believe life is
conception
i'm not pro-life but that's a scientific
fact okay uh libby if you don't mind can
ask that to you too if i think that life
begins at conception yeah i think it
probably does yeah um i do think though
that we are telling women the wrong
story i think we're telling the wrong
narrative about
um what life is about what meaning is
and what being a mother is all about uh
we tell women that our culture tells
women that um
their lives are limited when they become
mothers that it's going to put a damper
on your ability to do stuff right and
you know to a certain extent yes there
are limitations once you become a mother
you have to prioritize and you
prioritize differently
but
it's not going to ruin your life right
being a mother actually makes your life
that much better
it's a terrific bond it's a very deep
bond between mother and child
this is why i'm you know i'm very
pro-motherhood
and i think that it's important to tell
women poor women
because you know you're not seeing the
over-educated
white liberals running around getting
their abortions
you are seeing that as well um but women
are losing their rights in a lot of
other ways this is like the only right
that women are allowed to fight for
they're not allowed to fight to say that
they are women
they're not allowed to i don't know
far from where it's true or have any of
that i want to make i want to bring it
back together
your question you asked if life of
conception where were you going with
that i was just gonna say um i want to
reject that there isn't a middle ground
on this issue because i do believe i was
looking up the stats to try to find it
specifically but i think most people are
in the country i think it says right now
currently 59 say abortion should be
legal in in all or most cases while 39
percent say it should be illegal in all
most cases illegal i couldn't tell what
you said illegal or legal currently 59
say abortion should be legal in all or
most cases while 39 say should be
illegal in all or most cases so i think
there is a middle ground in our country
i think people already generally agree
that less than 20 weeks that's when most
abortions do occur they're cool with
that but late trimester i feel like most
people are on the same page about that
except the people on the fringe and i
think the the problem with this issue is
that the fringes are the most um
vulturous or voiceless uh about this
issue right the extremes are the ones
who care the evangelicals and the
religious people who say it starts at
conception and then you know crazy
abortionists who are who don't care if
it's until the moment of you giving
birth so that's how where the
conversation gets centered around even
though those are the most fringe cases
and that's the problem and why i think
some people don't think there is a
middle ground i think most people in the
country again 59 are cool
so i would agree with that
gallop has from 2021
48 believe abortion should be legal only
under only certain circumstances
32 say legal under any circumstances and
19 say illegal in all circumstances
which means the majority of americans
support restriction abortion i'm looking
at pew public opinion yeah so that shows
gallup says it's 50 50. it depends on
the statistics that you're looking at
yeah uh but i really want to say this so
it may absolutely be the case that there
are a large number of americans who say
that there's a middle ground here but 95
percent of biologists according to a
five-year study and survey of biologists
say that life begins at fertilization
regardless of their position on abortion
so the truth is life begins at
fertilization that's what the science
says and i believe that we need to base
our policy around the best information
we have on what human life is and
endowing every living person with said
rights not necessarily what the polls
say might be politically popular
real quick i do want to point out uh a
lot of stats i checked him yup hughes
says exactly what he says they show i'm
kosher but i will i will i will i
i will challenge them by saying when
provided with a more nuanced distinction
we can see from gallup three categories
as opposed to just two
when you're giving a binary choice on
legal or not some people might
begrudgingly say well i guess then in
we should just have it be legal when
given the option for limited
circumstance no circumstance or any
circumstance the plurality want
restrictions in some capacity as drugs
but again your poll was common and
ubiquitous the abortion pill is becoming
more common and ubiquitous you will not
have to go to a doctor to receive it in
the future so if women do choose to take
the abortion pill and terminate their
pregnancy what do you think our
government's response should be if there
is no doctor who prescribed the bill or
some it's some doctor in india a fake
doctor who's just selling pills right so
they acquired the abortion pill and they
chose to terminate their pregnancy how
should we penalize that woman i think
becomes the most politically
toxic thing you could do and that's
where it has to end up we don't want to
penalize the women but i feel like at
the end of the day if they're the one
who ends up making the choice then
that's where we end up that's kind of
total [ __ ] which part
penalizing women first wait so if a
woman chooses to take the abortion pill
that she got illegally then what should
the if abortion's illegal which of the
penalties you want to jail women for
terminating their i don't want to make
abortion illegal you don't want to make
abortion illegal but you if you do if it
is illegal you think that i'm going down
the steps no i'm going down the only
steps that makes sense so if we make
abortion illegal and somebody chooses to
get an abortion
these are j you know if we make a law
should someone be you know imprisoned
for attempted suicide
i don't think abortion should be illegal
which doesn't make any um i think you're
so i'd like to respond to this because
you're looking at a very specific
circumstances you're creating a
hypothetical scenario where all
abortions are obtained by women getting
these pills i'm talking about that
because sir so even if that does become
the case there's still going to be ways
to police other forms of abortion i
agree with you that some things are
going to slip through the cracks that
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
go prosecute women and it doesn't mean
we can't
prevent abortion in other scenarios so
how do you deal with the case so a woman
she's pregnant she gets an abortion pill
from india what do you what do we do
okay first of all there aren't abortion
pills that will terminate your
three-month-old okay so
like it's
the the abortion pills that exist are
pretty early term
okay so let's say very early term like
by the time you're three months like
okay there's a baby they work within the
first trimester 14 weeks so a woman
acquires a pill from india that induces
you know an abortion happened within 14
weeks and it's illegal in whatever state
she does it too i'm trying to get to the
base of it how do we penalize it and
there's no doctors no but i don't think
this is getting to the base of it
because we're talking about a
restriction that applies to abortions
across the state of oklahoma at all
points in conception with with a few
potential exceptions though i want to
look into what they're saying with
respect to those exceptions you're
talking about a specific scenario of
abortion pills that would be
particularly difficult to prove and
prosecute so i think what needs to
happen is you have to ensure that those
pills are not allowed in the united
states of america and anyone who sells
them you should ensure that
you're not listening
though what you're saying is because
this would be difficult to prevent it's
not something that we should attempt to
prevent how should we penalize it okay
well yeah i mean the dealership
i think makes a really good finish their
point before you just start talking over
each other i think sheamus makes a
really good point which is the dealer of
the abortion pills should be the one
who's held liability good luck trying to
go to india and well and then in those
cases you can't penalize anything that's
true of drugs i think that's the future
of abortion then in our country it's
people illegally acquiring abortion
pills when they can't receive them from
doctors and it's worth i think you can
get them up to 10 weeks i think the
future of abortion pill is going to get
it even further but i think to say that
there are instances that our laws can't
account for is not an argument for why
we shouldn't have these laws in the
first place the the argument is
if you think it should be illegal
because it terminates a human life
the issue is that you can't track
early human life
so
if you were to view abortion as no
different than a murder the issue is
that someone who is born and has a life
is tracked in some way and when they go
missing the murder typically not always
but will be noticed in some way someone
went missing a woman who gets pregnant
doesn't tell anybody then aborts the
baby there's no evidence of the
existence of the loss of human life
if you were to view it in the exact same
way that it was a murder then the law
should be treating it identically as it
was a murder that is to say it doesn't
matter how the women commit the act you
can drive from illinois to to you know
to indiana and illegally acquire a gun
and used to commit a murder
yeah it's still illegal so we will
penalize the woman is what i'm trying to
get to because if you think abortion is
murder and then the woman on her own
volition acquires and then aborts then
she murdered the child then not
necessarily because intent has a lot to
do with this so if a person doesn't
understand what they're doing they don't
recognizing that they're killing a human
person because they've been
propagandized no i think there's a good
point being made there because
yeah women are told that this isn't
murder so i think they're able to fight
in wars for insanity please no i don't
think so that's that's the basis of an
insanity plea that you didn't know right
from wrong you can't plead insanity
because you're literally insane you
plead you don't know the difference
between right and wrong so if you go to
court and they say you killed this has
happened a woman killed her kids because
she said that once they become 12
original sin will send them to hell
that's insane and then she
yes yes yes exactly so she bludgeoned
her kids to death
and then uh the court said why did you
do it she called the police after she
did it and she was like i need help
cleaning this up my kid i killed them
they said why and she goes to make sure
they went to heaven
so she was deemed insane yeah see that
that would be insanity so the issue is
if you want to penalize abortion as
though it were murder you would have to
treat the woman as a murderer yes well
so basically murder is handled by the
states and i would argue that as a
matter of legislation it makes sense to
be merciful to these women because
oftentimes they literally do not know
what they're doing they're told an
abortion is a procedure just like any
other where they're flushing some cells
out of their body and not a human life i
think so i would absolutely prosecute
the doctors because they know exactly
what they're doing i think there's a
vast majority of women in these
circumstances have no idea i totally at
100 disagree with you i think that women
women know what abortion is they know
what pregnancy is
and when you're pregnant you can tell
that you're pregnant a lot of things
change about your body very quickly and
you know that you're pregnant you know
that you're carrying a human life it's
apparent
um women
what intention
uh but you know that you're pregnant you
know what that entails um
no one doesn't know what they're doing
or thinks it really is a clump of cells
except perhaps you know girls under 16.
i do not think that women should be
prosecuted for having abortions any more
than i think people who are suicidal
should be prosecuted for attempted
murder it just doesn't make any sense
um these things you know these things
are going to happen women have been
aborting their babies since long before
birth control pills or whatever the uh
whatever abortion pills
or surgical procedures or anything like
that and there have certainly been
lots of circumstances in countries in
which women are prosecuted for having
abortions there was um
i was obsessed with norwegian literature
for a while and there was this book uh
growth of the soil i believe was it
growth of the soil yeah by newt hampson
and there was a woman
who was prosecuted for attempted
abortion and she ended up in prison with
a whole bunch of other ladies who had
attempted abortions and they were all
there raising their children in prison
um and that's the kind of thing that you
would start to look at you'd start to
look at imprisoning children
for having been born to mothers who have
a lot of kids
and didn't want any more
as it was in that book
was primarily the situation i think that
what we need to do as a society is have
more respect for
parents for parents choices we have to
be supporting families more and not
constantly trying to
you know force everyone to adhere to you
know the government's dictates for your
lifestyle i think that has a lot to do
with it you know there there is a chance
that the abortion pill doesn't actually
work they say uh the abortion is uh
results in abortion one to two weeks
anywhere from 54 to 92 percent of
pregnancies and it also says if the
abortion doesn't take it could result in
birth defects or if pregnancy doesn't
end
so
i think
i i would not be surprised
if uh they do ban abortion outright
across the board united states or just
in many states you're going to see
people fleeing states you're going to
see people doing you know backroom
abortions or whatever pills or otherwise
but i think what's more likely to happen
first is um geographic polarization yeah
so like what we're seeing with women in
texas fleeing to oklahoma
if now that oklahoma bans it you're
going to see people in texas fleeing to
colorado yeah and then they're going to
stay in colorado and then you're going
to see states become hyperpolarized by
it's going to be by geography then
you're going to see a bunch of states
that are pro-abortion with no
restriction and many states that are
anti-abortion with no exceptions or
limited rare exceptions like health the
mother and then it's going to come down
to the hyperpolarization of this country
control of our institutions and you are
going to have a strong moral issue for
people on the right who are like you are
literally murdering babies because we
saw it in virginia
when that woman was her name tran nancy
was it was her name that that politician
she wanted restrictionless abortion and
she was asked by a judge
would this mean that a woman who is
literally about to give birth she's
dilating you could abort the baby and
she goes
there would be no restriction
then you had northam say well we would
take the baby you'd be delivered it'd be
made comfortable and then the woman
would have a conversation with her
doctor about what to do next as if to
imply they would kill the baby after it
was already born there's something he
came out later and he was like i meant
in the case of severe defect i'm like
the baby's alive
well i also so so where does that lead
to
if people are going to flee these states
let me start from here
if roe v wade
is overturned as many believe it will
especially on the left
many have told me republicans will not
push for a federal ban on abortion
because they think it's a states rights
issue okay then you get all the blue
states saying no restriction on abortion
like they're doing already 15 states
that are seemingly into that degree and
then you have the red states all saying
ban an abortion with limited or no
exceptions you're going to have hyper
polarization in this country
and that is planting the seeds for
interstate conflict
we have that in a lot of areas though
also yeah well i find it fascinating i
agree with you i was just going to say
that though we're going to see increased
polarization just on the basis of
geography left-wing people are going to
leave these red states and then the blue
states are going to become bluer the red
states are going to become redder
because only people who are comfortable
with those abortion laws will move there
etc
you were making a point earlier just
about this being politically pragmatic
and what could happen is this going to
result in joe biden getting a second
term i don't think so but it's also an
interesting question because as we were
discussing earlier
there is a debate here over which side
cares more about this issue we were
pulling up different we were pulling up
different polls that had a bit of nuance
to the the question of abortion asking
do you think it should always be illegal
legal in some circumstances part of the
issue with these is they usually end up
with some kind of framing that could be
considered biased i know that gallup
pulled just straight up asked people do
you identify as pro-life or pro-choice
and it's a pretty pretty neat 50-50
split across the nation it's like 49
pro-choice 47 pro-life and then 5 with
no opinion i find it difficult because
two though because in that framing two i
feel like not all pro-lifers are from
conception errors i think that's
probably true yeah and a lot of like a
lot of people consider plan b abortions
and that's really and you're right
there's just so many gray zones there's
something to be said about political
principles though and political strategy
because you know i'm just saying it's a
bad strategy that doesn't mean it's
right or wrong
um so i think we have a lot of those
examples in our country who knows this
could be you know although a bad
strategy you're you're being very
principled i think it also kind of
relates to how trump's saying the
election was stolen and pragmatically
strategy wise i don't think it's a great
strategy but uh he's staying true to his
principles and the people who back him
up on those principles are getting
rewarded with his endorsement so yeah
well and i think part of what sort of
adds to my position you're here we'll
see we'll see what ends up happening but
part of what i think bolsters my
position is the fact that as tim said
pro-lifers see this as a child being
killed pro-choices just see this more as
in an abstract struggle between
religious fanatics and the secularists
who want to preserve people's rights
the question is do you care more about
that kind of abstract battle than you do
the fact that food is more expensive
you're having a harder time feeding your
family gas is as expensive as it's ever
been there's turmoil on the foreign
stage that we probably wouldn't see with
a president who is a little stronger
it's actually a toss-up and you're
probably going to care more about the
things that affect your life in a more
direct sense but if you're going to ask
people to balance those questions
against
another human life they're probably
going to choose to save the person or
believe in saving the person but in this
instance the pro-lifers don't even have
to make that choice because the people
who they would be voting for not only
want to end abortion but would ideally
be able to to get this country stuff
together and get gas prices down and
return food costs to something more
normal thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you